Wild pig or something.
Yeah.
My buddy from Australia gave me those and that head.
It's an Asian water buffalo.
It's an invasive species.
We live.
Oh,
it worked.
Jesus Christ.
Ladies and Gentlemen,
the UFC performance institute boys.
Hey,
what's this duck and Forrest Griffin.
Forrest Griffin.
Good to see you.
We've already talked over each other.
So guarded,
bloated.
No,
we've got it.
We've got it nailed.
Um,
well I'm really glad you guys are here because of,
I was blown away when I went to visit the,
you know,
you hear the performance institute and you go,
well what is this going to be like?
You go,
they were like,
oh my God.
They thought of everything.
It's like the ultimate state of the art facility for training,
for recovery,
for,
for nutrition.
It's fucking amazing.
I mean it was three that we're posting the link to that Shit.
Right?
Say it,
dude.
I mean it's,
it's amazing when,
when we went on a tour and check that place out,
I think it was the delegates who was with me.
Yeah.
We were like,
Holy Shit,
I can't imagine you have access to this fucking place.
Like you guys have really created something special.
It's very interesting.
And I don't know much about other sports,
but I know this never really existed in combat sports before.
Something like this.
That's,
I mean you guys have athletes from all sorts of different walks of life come
through there.
And when I was there,
there was many,
many top level fighters that were training out of there.
It's really,
really interesting.
Yeah.
Cool.
Well we appreciate the kind words obviously.
Um,
I mean ultimately,
yeah,
the,
the vision of the UFC was to build a performance institute that was truly a
world class high performance center that has everything that fighters would,
would need.
And not only are we trying to align ourselves as the leaders in mixed martial
arts,
but certainly leaders in human high performance can tell people what you do
there.
Explain.
Yeah.
So my role is the vice president of performance.
Um,
I essentially direct the,
the,
the philosophy of how are we going to interact with the fighters,
how are we going to support the fight is and obviously manage our,
our world class staff that are working within the performance facility.
And Clint,
you,
you came from a background in amateur wrestling and uh,
tell everybody like what your job is about.
Yep.
So I'm the director of performance nutrition,
so anything related to feeding of athletes,
it's essentially managed by myself and our ever expanding team.
So it could be as broad as working with athletes for their general training
plan,
integrating within the other performance services as well as feeding athletes on
the ground,
integrating with in our kitchen at the performance institute,
I'm supporting athletes as they prepare for for fight week,
wait,
descends,
et cetera.
And then supporting athletes on fight week and preparing at that even at the
last moment of fight day to fuel up and to be really well fueled for their
performance.
My background is,
like you said,
an amateur wrestling.
I wrestled and coached at Cornell University,
um,
graduated.
No three was on the US national team with a number of actually core current
fighters right now.
So core me at Daniel Cormier and a number of other athletes,
Chris Weidman and some others.
And I used to train together.
Um,
and then I went back to school and got all my,
my credentialing to be a registered
Dietitian.
And so that's kind of led me through developing a program at Cornell to the UFC
with a pretty unique combination of the nutrition,
the dietetics and then obviously the experience in combat sports and weight
cutting.
Yeah.
And in my opinion,
the most grueling combat sport.
I mean I think wrestling is just,
we talked about on the last podcast,
it's just,
it's crazy way for a kid to learn hard work and to learn real competition and
the state,
the actual physical struggle of getting to wrestling practice and strength and
conditioning grills.
Most kids that are coming up in high school and in college,
they don't really work that hard in any other sport.
I mean it's,
it's a crazy sport.
I remember in high school like walking into the wrestling room and it's a bunch
of gross dudes.
It's like in a sweaty hot room and then it was like basketball was right next to
it.
I walked because the basketball,
there's like dudes and tank tops and some like cheerleaders.
I'm like,
I know what I'm doing.
Maybe it's
a little bit,
I know little did you know?
Yeah.
I mean it's in my opinion still.
I think it's the most important skill because you get to dictate where the fight
takes place.
There's no one skill that really overpowers all except for the ability to hold
the guy down.
The ability to hold someone down and control them on the ground.
It's so critical and everything else you can learn from that.
Submissions ground and pound,
but the,
the,
the difference in like a,
an elite wrestler like yourself and a person who doesn't have that skill.
It's so hard to bridge that gap.
It is hard to learn later in life.
He's one of the few people that just like,
I'll just take this up and be amazing cause I'm GSP and then I'll become a
gymnast.
Who knows?
I think that's a thing with him though.
He had such physical abilities.
We were talking about this almost on the last podcast as well that he used to do
that karate blitz,
you know,
so he was,
he was so used to that lunging in stuff that he's sort of incorporated that with
a blast double and he's so physically strong.
It's such a smart dude and so,
so good at learning things that he just figured out the tech,
the essential techniques and he needed to master and just got better and better
at them way back in the day.
Obviously UFC one was kind of a discipline versus discipline.
Uh,
kind of grudge match.
And,
and having been a lifelong wrestler,
that's when I started tuning in and actually,
and taking pride in all the wrestlers,
taking names and,
and grown within the sport.
And obviously with the evolution of the sport,
um,
it's,
it's a different dynamic and obviously each athlete coming from their own
discipline is really fun for us to work with as practitioners having their own
kind of sport culture.
But wrestling is a obviously a core component to what each athlete is doing.
And when I'm working with athletes and talking through their weekly training
plan and you know,
how to feed and fuel for each of these types of training sessions and hearing
them bitch about how hard those wrestling practices are,
I always get a little bit of a little bit of pride.
They're like,
yes,
it is hard to imagine doing it for eight months straight for a college wrestling
season and grind that out.
But it's,
it's definitely been fun for me to watch wrestling as a component of MMA grow
and,
and be able to contribute to,
uh,
to,
to the sport on a,
on a few different kind of,
yeah.
I mean,
I think the way always looked at it as pressure
makes diamonds,
you know,
this is no other way you,
those,
uh,
those hard nose dudes,
they come out of those environments.
They do.
Like if you think about guys with crazy determination and,
and mental fortitude,
there's a giant chunk of those you could attribute to wrestlers,
but he's a lot of them and kickboxing and everything else as well.
But there's just seems to be,
it's such a unique sport in terms of hardening,
like your mental toughness for Shell.
I mean,
I wouldn't do it.
Fuck that.
Horrible.
I mean we at the performance institute,
we always talk about Mahershala mixed martial arts as the decathlon of combat
sports.
Um,
and I think our philosophy is to try and understand all the respective
components that makes a world class MMA fighter.
And I think,
you know,
if you're in the UFC,
you've got some certain x factors,
um,
that,
that allow you to be world class.
And you know,
wrestling is a huge component of that.
But what we try to do is understand limitations as well.
Because in a decathlon you're only ever as good as your weakest event.
Right?
Right.
So if you're a striker,
if you're a grappler or if you're a wrestler,
um,
you know,
we're trying to support each of those to understand how we can elevate the whole
thing.
Now how much input do you put into fighters,
if any,
into how they incorporate their skills and like how they combine their skills
together that you guys offer?
Like coaching on technique and approaches?
Yeah,
so break down the philosophy.
We don't do sports specific coaching,
so physical therapy,
sports nutrition,
a strength and conditioning in sports science.
And then Duncan oversees all those to make sure that their work.
All right.
So our philosophy,
anything that doesn't make you in the better in the octagon is pretty pointless.
So what,
what I do is I'll just go over what your training schedule looks like with you
and then,
you know,
where do we feed accordingly for this practice?
You know what?
And then Roman,
our sports scientists,
when you can,
you be recovered enough for this practice.
And that's,
you know,
that's the philosophy.
So it's not specific.
You're thinking about it.
If you guys are fighting and the performance institutes working with both you,
we make you as big,
strong,
healthy,
have the easiest time making weight,
go into your fight as fueled as you can.
But if I start saying,
hey,
you know what,
I,
he's,
he's pretty susceptible to late kicks.
Then it becomes,
you know,
now we can't support every athlete.
So when you talk to people,
it's just like,
here's how to get the most out of your practices,
right?
Here's the way to lay this out to just your training blocks.
I don't think a lot of people understand like basic training,
periodization leading up to a fight.
And then that's the other problem with the UFC.
You don't always have eight weeks,
10 weeks,
12 weeks,
sometimes you've got four weeks.
And it's like,
all right,
well,
where's your,
where's your wait?
Where are you at?
Where's your scale?
Where's it conditioning?
How can we put those things together in time to get you ready on,
you know,
but never specific like instruction on how to deal with the,
and that's um,
it's almost like
for a young to have the access,
first of all,
just the access to the physical facility,
like the,
just all the different modalities you guys have and you know,
the strength and conditioning stuff and the,
the fact that you can,
one of the most impressive things,
impressive things was the camera set up around the octagon so they could film
sparring sequences and techniques,
sequences and the fight.
Or you can back them up and rewind them and watch it and you can see,
oh,
see how you drop your leg here,
see how your,
you know,
your,
your chin is up in the air and all these different,
different little factors.
Thinking about the philosophy,
right?
You have to get close to game speed once or twice a week.
So for 15,
25 minutes,
you're going to get,
you're going to risk injury,
you're going to take physical damage that you're not getting paid for.
Make the most out of it,
right?
Like review it,
treat it like a fight.
Think about all athletes,
they fight two to four times a year.
So that's,
that's a very limited amount of actual footage they have.
But if you start recording your spine sessions and treating them like it,
like a fight,
like,
Asha,
I did this wrong,
I did that wrong,
then you're going to end up with more like 80,
90,
which is,
you know,
baseball,
basketball,
even football or that 20 plus games to,
you know,
review.
Yeah.
And I think it's really important for young fighters also to see themselves
doing certain techniques.
Like they might not notice.
They might think they look better than they do.
Like,
it's good.
My coach was full of Shit,
man.
And then you log the film,
don't lie,
and you're like,
yeah,
oh,
okay.
I see what I'm doing wrong.
It's hard sometimes to mimic,
you know,
without,
without actually seeing yourself.
Now you guys,
you been Forrest Griffin,
former UFC champion and motherfucking world.
Uh,
no one can ever take that from you,
sir.
How's that feel?
It's a beautiful thing.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
I've moved on.
I'm over it.
I'm now,
I'm VP of athlete development at the performance institute.
So it's much,
much more important.
But you still Forrest Griffin,
there's a lot of champions.
There's only one v P of athlete develop.
Kind of find that job to figure out what it actually does change.
Right.
Daily.
Don't worry about it.
Um,
you have been involved from the beginning of this,
right?
Yeah.
Uh,
so it was going on about two weeks in,
I heard this was happening and I was like,
oh,
hey guys,
I worked for you.
I'm doing community outreach right now,
but I've been trying to figure out the best way to train for mixed martial arts
for the last 18 years.
I don't know.
Maybe give me a shot at it.
So,
yeah.
Now when you,
when you say that,
that you're trying to figure out the best way,
is there a best way?
Yes.
For everybody.
For every,
unfortunately it's this bullshit answers.
Everybody's different,
man.
Everybody's got a different ability to work,
you know,
like,
uh,
Uzma and might have x amount,
you know,
before he physically breaks down,
because look at him.
He's a fucking Ferrari,
right?
He,
he,
he needs more high end work or whatever.
Everybody's a little physically different.
The key is to get some objective feedback to know,
hey art,
I'm in the red.
I'm,
I'm good.
I'm not,
you know,
do you,
do you guys do it on a heart rate,
heart rate variability?
Like we need to determine whether or not someone's recovered?
Tell him about a mega wave.
Yeah,
I mean there's plenty of different ways to do it at the most,
the most basic level.
It's just speaking to a guy and get feedback.
Right.
How are you feeling?
Is One of the best questions that we can ask her an athlete,
but,
um,
yeah,
I mean we're,
we're blessed and we're privileged with pretty high resource at the UFC
performance institute.
So we have some pretty involved technologies.
One of the ones that we use is as a system called mega wave and that gives us
real insight and removes the subjectivity where it can get objective
understanding around physiology,
particularly looking at and the DC potential of the brain.
So really see the DC potential.
The brain is an assessment of the autonomic nervous system.
Yeah.
So if you look at,
if you look at the parasympathetic and sympathetic balance of your body,
we're talking science now.
I apologize.
But ultimately that's one of the things that's really impacted.
There you go,
Jamie pulled something up on the screen here.
John Smith,
see windows of trainability.
This is fascinating.
And so mega wave or is it something you were,
yeah,
so ultimately it's um,
it's a three to five minute assessment.
You wear something that resembles a heart rate strap laying at rest and we also
have electrodes and Anya on,
on the third eye of your brain essentially.
Um,
so we're picking up cardiovascular stress and we're picking up the autonomic
nervous system and we're looking at things like heart rate variability,
which you've already mentioned.
But so this isn't for everybody.
Some people love it and they say,
hey man,
this is,
you know,
again,
these are just tools,
right?
So different tools for different people,
Yeah,
for sure.
It's a,
it's a first thing in the morning measurement too,
to understand your,
your recovery,
how well you're recovering from the day before and those windows of trainability
for the next day.
I think it all comes back to what far says.
Ultimately what we're trying to do is understand individual responses.
Right?
At the end of the day,
everyone's on a pathway of um,
performance mastery to be a world champion.
And people respond to the workloads,
the intensities,
the volumes in very different ways.
If we take a basketball team and put them all through the same workout,
you've got 15 different guys that are responding in very different ways to the
same workout.
Um,
so we're,
we're,
we're privileged in that we work with an individual sport and that's how,
that's how our mantra is that we're looking at every single athlete is an
individual and what building our programs,
programming strategies and our information in an individual way.
So you guys have been doing this now for how many years and we're coming up on
two years on May 22nd is a,
is our second anniversary.
And do you do to have like a,
a log of all the different cases you worked with so you can kind of review like
what methods were more effective than others and you're constantly trying to
improve this protocol or how you guys,
how do you guys write it all out?
I mean we've obviously been involved with numerous fight camps.
Um,
but we're also working with fighters that are not in camp.
last year we presented this,
um,
Journal,
our first journal,
which is a,
an overview across section of all the data that we accrued in our first 12
months and we continue to aggregate that data.
Now one of the privileges that we have at the institute is we get the
opportunity to work with just under 600 faces on our roster so we can create
real clear cross section and awareness what different weight classes look like,
what the challenges are to a fighter.
And then,
you know,
the fighters can compare and contrast themselves against their immediate peers
in their weight class.
So that's one of the most powerful benchmarking tools you can create this or
mega wave technology.
Can people buy that?
Oh yeah.
It's just a commercial product off the shelf and it looks like it worked off an
APP.
Like you,
you put an APP on your phone.
Yup.
Seems like it seems like that's the future.
But again,
we use many different types of technologies.
You know,
things like force plates can,
can look at neuro muscular responses.
Um,
some of our nutrition variables will change across time.
So it's not just one tool that has given us all the answers that the windows of
trainability concept is something that really helps us on a day to day basis to
understand can you go into a strength or power type session today and really
maximize the opportunity to create that applications another day.
The year end jury might be an insurance emphasis.
So what it allows us to do is just give,
give kind of Kudos and credence to the athlete to understand where's the best
approach and where are you going to optimize your responses
in every other sport.
It's easier to train for them.
MMA who think about it.
I was a defensive end in high school.
Every defensive end needs the same physical abilities.
You think about the uh,
combine the NFL combine for instance.
They've figured out over a million years what they want to test for.
And like the,
the guys that,
that,
you know,
they,
they run the same,
the jump,
the same per position,
right?
So quarterbacks donated to necessarily be that fast if they can throw it right.
But for everybody else,
the numbers are kind of the same for our sport.
And they've collected,
I dunno,
I dunno how many data points at this point.
It's a lot.
So they're anonymized,
normalize.
So you know what average looks like,
what you know,
so you can give a guy like Anthony Smith say,
hey look man,
if I bring him up,
because he's mentioned it before,
he's been outspoken about,
you know,
working with the Pii,
hey,
you know what,
you're forced power measurements.
They're pretty average for two oh five.
You're not,
you're not a weak guy.
You don't,
you could think about going up a weight class.
So it's just objective information.
So the athletes and hopefully their coaches can make those choices.
Do you think they would benefit from more weight classes?
Oh,
that's a great question.
I,
so I thought ha 65 you know,
look at the percentages and then you know,
I was talking to actually Dana and Sean and there was like,
well this guy's going to go to 65 this guy's going to go to six to five.
Everybody's kind of go.
So is it going to help?
I mean,
there needs to be a percentage difference,
but I don't know.
I think people would just say,
well shit,
now I have to do an extra five pounds.
But again,
so from a PCI standpoint,
that's not really a decision we have to make.
What we need to do is collect as much data as we can on that and for individual
fighters trying to figure out which,
and then also to provide that information to,
you know,
third party commissions.
It's just so many,
there's the gaps.
You know how these days it's okay and I know what you're doing.
Well you can from 85 to two oh five,
that's 20 pounds.
That is an enormous jump.
So how do you decide like when a is a tweener,
like how do you
look at a guy who maybe ways to 15 and go,
damn dude,
those are the numbers.
Like what's your path?
What's your speed?
Are you a good athlete for that weight class?
All right,
not,
yeah.
What's your online?
How does that,
you know,
how does your arm like,
and the way you fight,
right?
So if you're Tyson ski,
you can have short arms and you Russell got like a gray Maynard style,
right?
That's fine.
You don't need super long arms.
But you know,
if you're not a wrestler you don't have the head move.
Maybe you do anyway.
We've actually had a number of athletes I would say over the last year come to
us specifically.
And sometimes it's matchmakers who were saying,
Hey,
this guy wants to go down.
Come,
come,
take a look,
meet with the Pi Staff,
see what,
see what you guys think.
Um,
all of those things that Forrest said are really valid.
We do have a lot of a battery of tests,
both in the nutrition space around body composition,
around metabolic
function.
Uh,
oftentimes bad weight cuts will diminish and depressed the metabolic rate,
the resting metabolic rate as well as,
as it progresses over time through,
through training.
Um,
and then like we said,
some of the energy systems,
a lot of the strength and power diagnostics.
How does an athlete compare to the,
the,
the norms and the standards that are set for that division?
So first things,
first thing that I look at is how does,
how does their body fit into a division?
Uh,
everybody's body is broken into three components.
If you think about it in terms of bone,
muscle and fat.
And if somebody's fat,
free mass,
it's everything except for their,
uh,
their fat is 90 is bigger than 99% of the athletes in that way.
Division,
it's not going to be a good fit.
So a big thing is benchmarking,
understanding how somebody body fits into their division compared to others.
So that's Kinda step one.
Then we look through all of these other different metrics to see how they
compare.
And then we have a conversation.
So my job has never,
especially working with independent contractors,
they can use us or they can,
they can not.
And we are a resource to consult and to have conversations with them,
uh,
about what makes sense on a scientific level.
Can I ask you how that works is like I've saved someone like a Henry pseudo or
some wants to do his camp.
Yep.
Uh,
at the UFC performance institute.
How would they do schedule it with you guys?
Tell you I'm going to be here for eight weeks.
We set up camp in Vegas,
we'd like to do it at the,
at the gym.
So it happens all the time,
whether it's a week or or eight weeks that that filters into every single member
of our team,
especially as we're doing more and more on the ground at fight events.
But that gets filtered up to Dunkin and then Dunkin handles the coordination of
that.
It could literally be there with safe.
He was gonna Fight Marlin Mariah's.
They literally could be in the performance institute at the same time for shill
and that that happens.
Split level facility.
They're never in the same zone at the same time you scheduled it.
I wouldn't be doing MMA in the octagon.
You schedule them first come first serve.
Do you ever anticipate a problem like with guys that are supposed to be fighting
each other?
You know like what just happened with Mazda doll recently?
Like we're an actual fist fight breaks out man.
You find most of these guys want to get paid
to fight and not pay to fi.
Right.
But when you see like the camera's on and on then not so yeah.
That fight.
Yeah,
that's true.
Right.
When the cameras aren't on.
The other thing is when you're leading into a fight and my thought was you
cannot let that person think they intimidated you.
And if that means you actually have to hit them,
maybe it does.
But the,
the,
you know,
the idea is that I can't let you think that you have a mental advantage,
right.
In any other sports.
So we know why I ever want to see that.
Like he was like,
you gotta stop that.
But in fighting it's like,
oh,
they just do an extra fighting.
Yeah,
right.
I was like,
you guys are getting paid.
Yeah.
Look,
if it's a basketball player,
sucker punches another basketball player in the face.
It's some sort of a press conference like that,
like Mazda doll did.
I mean you'd be like,
what?
No Way.
But in fighting like,
oh,
these are did extra fighting.
You don't get extra buddy or extra credit
for that performance was going to get extra money.
Stunning.
Knock out of Darren tills,
one of the top guys in the Welterweight Division,
the weight k Odin was crazy.
So he got it from that and then to tee off on Leon Edwards after the fight like
that,
it's like another one like that.
It's part of that is very good for him,
unfortunately.
Like I don't want him to do that.
I don't,
I don't want encourage,
but if you want to think about like a fighter's popularity
he's in,
I don't give a fuck,
I'll punch you in the face guy.
And they're like,
wow.
A lot of people are now.
He's a real,
and I don't give a fuck.
I'll punch you in your face guy.
They're real.
They're really exists and he's a world class fighter like that's a,
that's sellable.
It's unfortunate.
I wish guys wouldn't ever fight at press conferences like Cormier and Jon Jones.
I fucking hated that.
But tell me that didn't sell more tickets.
No doubt.
That's sold a shitload more tickets.
How many times they throat show show and that Dolly,
oh,
how many times they show that even in the promos.
I hated when that happened.
There was a terrible thing to Conner did that got,
damn,
that sold some tickets.
That's a,
that's a fine line,
right?
That's kind of a funny thing.
People that weren't even involved got cut.
You got hit with glass.
Get canceled on me that,
I mean using it promoted.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
We just tried to avoid it and hide it or do we let people know that this is a
real thing?
They call all,
all people involved.
Go,
look,
this is a business.
We're here to get paid.
Okay,
we're going to run it.
We're going to run it every 15 minutes.
I'm going to show that Dolly Smash.
Oh,
and that's we'll Harris's company.
Is that the gentlemen?
What is it?
What is it called?
Anatomy of a fighter.
Yes.
That's his youtube show that I often thought was a UFC show.
I didn't even know that he had his own show.
There's so many good guys right now that are putting out good content.
It's will Harris.
Yep.
And uh,
he came in here with Camaros.
Mine,
Super Nice Guy.
But his,
uh,
his footage is his,
that was his footage of that Dolly smashing it.
The window.
So the thing you see over and over again,
thank will,
I think the embedded guys from the UFC
were on the bus as well,
so they got
congratulated on the outside.
Jesus Christ.
Anyway,
sorry about that.
Hey listen man,
this is how this show works.
It goes off the rails occasionally.
Um,
it is,
uh,
what,
what you guys have set up though is kind of an impressive thing and the combat
sports world,
but he's never anything like this for boxing were boxers can go and it's closest
to the Olympic model.
So we went around benchmarking and Yada Yada,
60 plus facilities.
And you notice like a lot of the people that we hired worked with International
Olympic sports and that's kind of our athlete model,
right?
So Olympic athletes,
they might go to Colorado Springs for two weeks or for four months or for a
week,
um,
and do like a skills camp or something for we,
we have the same model.
You come in three,
four days and then go home with like a program,
you know,
with Daya,
shrike traditional program,
PT program,
your training load goals,
et cetera.
So you'd leave with that,
right.
And then maybe,
you know,
you can't,
you don't want to move your life to Vegas.
You got family kids back home.
So you'd come out three days every other month and they can actually monitor and
tell you this is how your training's going.
It's just again,
just data on whether it,
it's working or not working as opposed to my old boxing coach knocked today kit.
But it's good.
I was like,
I eat cookies last night.
Punch hard.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Um,
the scientific approach of getting those little extra percentage points of
improvement is really what it's all about.
And it could really be the difference.
And it's such a crazy sport because it's so wild and unpredictable and you mean
you could speak to this better than anybody?
The results may vary,
but it is a wild goddamn sport.
I had one of the best camps I ever had was a Keith chardy the aggressor while I
was fucking amazing in the gym.
Now I was like,
I am so good right now.
I beat everybody up.
This is amazing.
But you know,
it was a 14 week camp started falling apart then
with as many degrees of freedom is mixed martial arts.
All right.
In terms of execution,
well,
just syncing the stylistic backgrounds,
white classes,
you don't even know when Dana is going to give you a call to the next fight.
Let's,
let's look at Usain Bolt,
right?
There's a reason why you saying bolt is a hundred meter champion and he's not
the 60 meter champion.
All right,
our guys,
if,
if you look at mixed martial arts,
that is six to 36 seconds of high intensity work,
followed by two to three times as much low intensity work repeated throughout
our five minute round.
77% of fights are won in those high intensity efforts,
right?
So that's where the fight is won in lust,
but you don't know if that six seconds is going to be the first six seconds of
the fight or the last seconds of the fight.
So Usain bolt knows that he's going a hundred a hundred meters.
All right?
Our guys don't know if there needs to be the the best starter,
the best finisher.
So you've got to prepare for everything.
So all,
all these degrees of freedom,
these various external variable things
that come into mixed martial arts make it the most complex bought to figure out
and build a structure and a development pathway.
Again,
it's so interesting too that so many different fighters ever.
Completely different approach.
Like you've gotten a low volume,
high power approach,
like maybe your Tyron Woodley and then you've got a guy like Nick Diaz who just
smothers guys.
He just stays on you and keeps punching you and talking shit to you and he sees
you starting to lose your breath and it keeps coming after you.
And he can push a pace because of his long term cardiovascular condition.
I mean it's,
it's,
and you can't tell him he's doing it wrong because not everybody's doing it as
sometimes your physiology,
right.
It's going to determine the way you fight.
Right?
Like the arm length,
the John Jones and the leg and arm length clarify like that.
Cause I'm gonna get,
I'm not going to be at the end of everybody's punched just that are rich.
I'm going to be getting hit by everybody if I start throwing those tapes,
you know?
And also it allows him in training to like get better.
Like he's always got this.
So he's got this advantage.
He's like constantly getting better and he's also the best I've ever seen at
utilizing that reach.
He's very good at keeping his opponent exactly where he needs him and in in his
range and then when they close up,
he's very good at being defensive.
I mean it's,
it's,
I mean that's what the best fighters do,
right?
The tend to fight whether they want it to go,
but it's just so interesting to see that everyone does have a different approach
that they make work with their body structure.
It's quite unique because we've looked at a lot of our physiological assessments
and when you take the data and you compare and contrast,
for example,
people with grappling and wrestling backgrounds versus striking backgrounds,
you can take something like power and you can differentiate between those two.
So,
all right,
I want to get a competitive advantage as a striker and might need to improve my
strength work because the wrestlers are already stronger than me.
We can look at the,
the,
the strength characteristics and you know,
our data shows that those comes with the,
the,
the guys that come from a wrestling background are far and above stronger than
the strikers,
which you would expect,
right?
But if you look at things like can you differentiate our top 15 in the world
versus the rest of the roster and that weight class,
it just,
it,
it takes away any comparative,
um,
any comparison.
And at the end of the day,
ultimately in a complex chaos based sport,
skill is always going to be the best determinant of performance.
So we're not saying that the physiological variables aren't important to the
sport of MMA,
but it's really hard to tease out where you need to push your strategy and where
you need to optimize your training.
Because in a,
in a,
in a homogeneous population of world class fighters,
it kind of gets absorbed and it becomes invisible where the differences are
important point.
We usually are a little more specific per app or should they just told me what
not to do.
What do I do though?
Well,
and that's where the individualization,
personalization for every single athlete comes in.
We find their strengths and some of their,
their gaps where it might be the lowest point scoring component of their
decathlon of MMA.
And if it's a deficiency that maybe hasn't been taken advantage of yet but will,
that's
where we fill those gaps so that they can start to fill those holes and become
more complete,
more comprehensive.
That might be strength,
power.
It might be energy system,
it may be,
it could be anything.
It could be orthopedic.
I mean we,
we have,
we're,
we're trying to assess every component of preparation that can support or limit
that athlete's performance in the cage in terms of,
you know,
how they,
all those things work together is really vital.
That if somebody is working on their strength and power,
they're not feeding their,
their body in a way that's actually limiting their ability to perform in the
high intensity training.
Right.
Because then that limits the adaptation that we're looking for as a response to
that training.
And that's,
that's a really critical point where nutrition,
Phil's really is a foundation that supports the development of all the other
adaptations that that,
that are required to become that complete mixed martial artists.
So as the strength and conditioning plan is being laid out as the physical
therapy plan,
as the recovery plan,
all of those are are coming to fruition.
The nutrition obviously is really near and dear to what I'm doing is really
critical at supporting the adaptation so that we're not pulling the bus,
you know,
the,
the athlete in two different directions.
In terms of the adaptation now
in terms of when you take fighters and athletes into your performance institute,
have you guys ever worked with young junior,
like amateur mixed martial artists,
kids that are coming up and do you ever do stuff like that and show them like
give them a peek at what it's like to see like the world class fighters?
We don't have the performance institute in Las Vegas because we're very much
aligned to supporting our current roster and it's a facility and a philosophy
that's been designed to support our current roster.
What we're doing in June of this year,
however,
is opening up a facility in Shanghai,
China and which will have a completely different business model in terms of that
will be very much a developmental program for guys that aren't in the currently
in the even state.
So obviously we're trying to improve the talent standards in,
in China and,
and develop that market and break that new territory.
But the mechanism to do in that is going to be very much to talent development
in the performance institute.
So over there we will have um,
MMA coaches and grappling coachees and striking coaches.
We don't have that in Las Vegas because we're currently working with guys that
are already on the roster.
Well,
it's such a unique sport in the fact that even though it is one thing when you
get into the UFC,
the paths to get there are so widely different and you really don't know what
the right wing is the cro cop path the right way to do it or is it Daniel
Cormier a path,
the right way to do it?
No one can say and different fighters will win on different nights with
different styles.
It's d one of the only sports where your pathway in.
You could say that if someone isn't elite kickboxer or an elite grappler that
going in with that one major advantage in that one skillset could,
could take you very,
very far versus an overall game approach that some guys have.
They're really good at everything.
Right.
And the true specialist,
if you look at the day,
the true specialist,
the GSPS of this world still hasn't necessarily risen to the top in the sport of
MMA.
You still see guys that are stylistically,
they have a stylistic emphasis and that's the x factor that keeps them at the
top of the game.
Yeah.
And,
and then there's execution,
which is creativity and their ability to perform under pressure or their ability
to maintain their cool during camp where they never overtrained and they stay in
a good space,
stay in a good headspace.
And I've girlfriend problems or boyfriend problems.
And then they get to the final night of the competition with the most in the
tank.
And that's a,
that's an art in and of itself,
right?
So when you first asked about,
you know,
something,
I've seen that I love,
uh,
training partners,
right?
So bring your training partners to the UFC,
Pii.
And we've had,
I dunno,
six,
seven,
eight guys that came in as training partners and are now on the UFC roster.
So that's,
that's why I'm not an asshole to anyone.
That's cause you never know.
I so you get to chance to see these,
I mean every guy has to start somewhere.
Every girl has to start somewhere.
You get a chance to see these people that may maybe never get this invitation
there and they see the holy ground like God damn,
I think it's performance as well.
To your point too about the facility,
world class facility,
the services we would argue are even better than the facility.
But training partners,
coaches,
those that are on the contender series,
those that came through for the ultimate fighter,
they have all been able to use and to access the facility in short periods,
training partners can come and access the facility,
eat on campus,
uh,
strength,
train with the UFC athlete,
use the facility upstairs and,
and train in the MMA space.
And when they get the chance that when they get the shot,
then they tap right into services and,
and,
and it,
it's an opportunity for us to,
you know,
essentially influenced the community even before we're working with them
directly,
which is,
which is a really huge component of our,
our philosophy and really what we're looking to accomplish.
I think it would be massively inspirational for the fighters too.
Yeah.
I mean,
our philosophy is to accelerate the evolution of the sport of mixed martial
arts.
That that's in our mission statement saying when you,
when you walked through the door,
it's right there on the wall,
you know?
And,
and to do that too,
we're trying to shift the barometer in terms of not the professionalism of the
sport,
but the expectations of fighters within the spot.
You look at someone like Brown a tagger and listened.
What,
what we're not trying to do is take the wild out of the stallion,
right?
We're not trying to just push science at fights is at the end of the day,
these guys have a world class fighters for a reason.
But you can train and shape the stallion and it still has the wild at heart,
right?
So what we're trying to do is shift the barometer.
So there's an expectation of what a professional athlete should,
should really expect.
Brian a tagger is worked out in his garage,
most of his crit garage.
Sorry.
Um,
but in terms of,
you know,
what's the expectation that professional fights it should expect and the
performance institute demonstrates that,
you know,
not everyone can have access to it,
obviously,
but that's an aspiration and it's,
it's where people should understand in the sport of mixed martial arts,
the standard as a fighter you can
expect.
And it's uh,
it's so important.
I think that you put all these things under one roof like that and create this
environment because it,
it seems to be trickling off into other places.
Like the,
the level of training and recovery and everything is so intense.
It's so severe that people are starting to try to mimic certain aspects of that
in their,
their own gyms and their own different places.
The problem is you can't do things in isolation.
All right?
If you just say,
right,
I'm going to really hammer the recovery piece and forget about the nutrition
piece.
It's,
it's a large machine,
right?
That there's cogs and all the cogs need to work together.
And that's what we truly feel we can offer and we can deliver is this into not
necessarily a multidisciplinary service,
but an entire disciplinary service where we have multiple aspects coming
together to fill the whole picture of an athlete's portfolio of needs.
And,
and that's what we can offer through the performance institute we want to do is
figure out what the best practices are and disseminate them.
Like,
we don't want to just know a bunch of stuff so we can keep it.
Remember,
we want every other gym like,
Hey,
here's what we've learned.
This is how we do our recovery.
Take a tag of it,
try it.
See if you're covering,
see if you want to laser bed.
Maybe you do,
maybe you don't.
This is what we've found success in.
You know,
so you want to,
you know,
what's the point of learning something and then hiding their way please.
And everything's about assessment.
So it's not one recovery modalities,
not one nutrition modality is not one strength and conditioning.
It's assessing.
So then we could build that personalized approach.
And so here are the modalities.
Here's the philosophy that we've developed to help optimize athletes needs
around what,
what,
what we're measuring and we're not winning fights.
That that's obvious.
That comes with the x factors that comes from the fighters there,
their passion and their commitment to their sport.
But what we're trying to do back back to your original question,
I think around this 1% is so hard to measure,
but what we're able to do is to help them to do it more consistently and to do
it longer into their career so that they can,
they can optimize,
they can maximize their ability to train,
to adapt,
to perform and give themselves the best chance to be successful on fight night.
Jan,
there must be so many fighters that come from a discipline,
whether it's judo or something along those lines,
and then they start fighting and MMA,
so they get a boxing coach and they have a few guys working with them with leg
kicks,
but they don't have a nutrition guy and they don't have a recovery guide.
I don't have someone who understands like deep tissue massage.
They had to find that guy,
they got to find someone to organize a diet for them.
They've got to figure out how to cut weight,
healthy,
proper.
And there's,
these things are so difficult for fighters to put,
especially you don't live in a place that has something like American top team
or some gigantic institution.
Yeah.
I mean that,
that,
that's fights is a even top fighters on our roster of bank potentially hire a
nutritionist for a short period of time in if fight can,
you know,
for an eight week period this,
this should be a 52 week fight camp.
We should become central in our development as fight isn't as athletes,
professional athletes,
50 to 52 weeks of the Aa and now,
and I think that's too,
that's,
that's what our philosophy is as Clint has already talked about.
Um,
in terms of plugging the holes and being able to offer the services that you
need as a particular athletes.
So there's,
there's large gyms out there,
American top team,
Aka,
they've got their own guys.
That's,
that's great.
Jackson,
they've got their own people.
Um,
but you know,
w w there's plenty of people on the roster that have an MMA coach and a
grappling coach.
And that's it.
So the performance institute,
we,
we feel we can help them support those guys as well.
Right.
And we're not trying to displace the programs were athletes already have
resources but I don't know of another MMA gym globally that has the capacity
around assessment that we do.
So yeah,
we have,
we have some really great practitioners but both San of our strength coach and
his team cannot write programs for 570 athletes.
It's not possible.
But what we can do is assess those athletes,
provide that feedback back to their strength coaches and have conversations
about how those coaches can use that data to,
to support the development of that athlete and that that goes across the board
for all of our performance services.
What's pretty amazing resource because if you're a young fighter and all you
have is access to the people around you,
you get,
if you're fighting in the UFC,
you get to have access like instantaneously to this gigantic group of people
where it's like when forest,
when you were coming up,
you mean you were a real pioneer.
I mean that was,
that was not available to a guy.
Like,
you know,
I mean,
I tell the story all the time,
but,
so I was actually a little bit ahead of my time.
I had,
you know,
I had an actual strength coach that had letters behind his name,
went to college to be a strength coach,
not there was like an x body builder.
Uh,
I had,
uh,
you know,
a relatively good nutritionist who at least had a degree in chemical biology.
Uh,
I had a good physical therapist,
but I didn't really have,
like,
I was my coach at the end of the day,
I was the head of performance.
So I'd go do Jujitsu,
Jujitsu coach wants you to go hard and then he'd go kickbox,
but you're going to go light,
but it's kicked by us or you don't.
And then,
you know,
and now,
nobody's the strength coach and nutritionist on different pages.
So I think just understanding that everything has to work together,
which I didn't really understand.
Well,
the one I'm saying is that you kind of had to pave a path because when a guy
like you was doing all that stuff with a real legitimate strength and condition
coach,
real legitimate nutritionist,
how many other people were doing that at your time?
Not that many,
but
beer on good people like Randy couture,
chocolate belt.
Those were kind of guys I got to hang out with and say,
well,
he does this.
He does a chuck actually what ended that much of this stuff.
But Randy was was right.
I know what I'm doing.
Okay.
All right.
Yes sir.
Yeah,
he just existed on pure savagery.
Um,
when you step back and look at your career,
like how,
how amazing is it to be able to step off from there and do something like you're
doing now for the UFC performance institute was just very meaningful for young
fighters.
When you really do get a chance to give back with your experience and your
understanding of the right way and the wrong way,
the mistakes you've made.
I mean,
it's huge.
I mean that's the whole,
I mean that's the whole genesis cannot from,
from my involvement in the pie like,
oh look,
here's the 10,000 mistakes I made.
You're going to make mistakes too.
But he,
these are the ones you don't need to make.
You know,
again,
the sports change man,
it's 25 years old.
Every other sports so evolved,
been around so long.
Our sport changes all the time.
I forget who was talking about it,
but you know,
even the guys fighting 10 years ago probably couldn't compete with guests
fighting today,
you know.
But I mean what I would say as well and is not only for the fighters forest is a
huge results for us.
The best of the best piece of technology we have is that they'll handle it leads
from my office to forest office,
right?
Because ultimately he's a massive results for us that are not necessarily coming
from an NMA background and are trying to support the MMA community to,
to bounce ideas off to essentially Beta test things from a thought process
perspective.
And he's a huge part of the performance institute philosophy because we can use
and call upon his expertise.
Here's another funny thing.
When we were putting together the,
the uh,
the team for the Pi,
I kind of shied away from people already doing MMA.
I want to combat sports.
Everybody that's done it has done judo boxing on an Olympic level.
They've done combat sports.
But I wanted like a fresh set of eyes coming from a different,
you know,
than just ah,
cause I know really good MMA strength coaches.
I know pretty good.
Emma,
you know,
you,
good but get,
get that fresh set of eyes.
You know,
nutrition actually was a little different because the rest of the world does not
understand awake cut for an MMA fight.
It's not like a,
you know,
we go to exos who go to any high level facility and that you said I'm going to
lose 8% of my body weight and then competed on Saturday.
They were like,
no,
don't just fight in the highway class.
And I'm like,
yeah,
that actually isn't going to work out for me.
They just won't comprehend it though.
Like,
no,
no.
You'll perform better.
Like,
Nah.
So we'll know we have some money.
It's,
that's another thing about having limited amount of weight classes when you jump
up.
Chance crazy man.
He's like one 74 [inaudible] 75 on fight day.
Yeah.
Fighting guys one 90 yeah,
but with a lot of energy Z.
Yeah.
What's interesting is at his age,
I think it's probably the only meals.
Yeah.
I think it's probably a good move though at his age.
You know,
I think he's back from UFC.
Ultimate fighter was inside.
We knew though,
like on the show that he was the one they would go forever.
We'd be with a house that I know.
A just crazy awesome.
Still gotta stop.
I mean when w when he beat Micky Gall that way,
I was,
I was incredibly impressed when I like this kid might test them.
He didn't test him at all.
I mean it was amazing.
It's a prime Diego Sanchez performance 15 years into the game.
I mean it doesn't even,
not even just into,
that's just into the UFC.
He had amateur fights and our professional fights rather before the UFC,
he spent in the UFC for 15 years or at least 14.
Right?
2004.
2005 was season one.
We shot it 2004.
so yeah.
Yeah.
Somewhere,
somewhere in the neighborhood of 15 years.
Just amazing that he's so enthusiastic about it.
It's still,
yeah,
they'll give him a vase for his top of his mantle piece on it,
but his fire or something,
carriage clock or something just to recognize is 15 years.
Yeah.
That's um,
that's a long time,
uh,
in a combat sport,
long time.
So that's the other thing,
man,
that is not the norm.
That's a deviation.
Right.
Either you got it for,
I made it nine years in the UFC,
eight years actually.
And you know,
I didn't have that many fights.
I broke down,
I fell apart.
It's pretty average,
you know,
I was like,
Whoa,
is me?
And then when you look at the data,
it's like,
oh no,
I'm,
I'm just average 35.
That's,
that's when you start fall apart.
When you look back now with what you know now and all the athletes you've worked
with at the UFC pie,
do you think you would've done anything different?
I pay even think about it.
I knew how to fake about it.
All right.
Yeah.
Yes sir.
Down
eight rounds.
Why would you party rounds?
There's no eight route fines for us.
Oh,
you literally just getting slower.
Forced you already slow.
I don't know.
No,
it's uh,
again,
being a pioneer like you were,
there wasn't really a whole lot of guys before you that were operating had the
other pioneers like the Randy's and the chunks and that's what they were doing.
So better be tough about it or do what they do.
That's the craziest thing about MMA is I'm not going to question them.
Boxing it already figured out.
You shouldn't beat the fuck out of each other every day.
They had already kind of figured that.
The other thing they've figured out is,
uh,
we would work with peep,
would spar with Vandelay,
chuck,
Randy inboxing.
They don't spar with people.
That equals past a certain point in camp.
We'll think about it.
You know a lot about,
they start like is Floyd Mayweather sparring with,
I don't know,
really good people his level?
No,
no,
definitely not.
He's,
he's funny people.
Boxers and he's tool in them.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
But they think,
have you heard of them though?
They're not famous and rich,
so they're not the best in the world.
They're not elite.
Whereas you think about like a gym,
like our gym.
Like I'll just use Randy's cause I don't want to talk bad about anybody.
You're fighting other champions every day.
Right.
Maybe.
Maybe dangerous as fuck.
Yeah.
Maybe drill together.
Sure.
Learn from each other.
Role Wrestle,
like control your training,
especially guys that are in the same way.
Classes you that may some day fight you.
That's awkward.
Yeah.
And there was no guidebook.
You know,
you know guys like Keith Jardeen and Rashad Evans figured it out.
They're like,
all right,
we already had to fight each other.
We'll turn it together now we won't have to do it again.
Right.
It's good move if it works out.
Um,
the,
the level of guys now is,
it's so extraordinary to see,
like when you see the elite champions of today,
you just have this insane level of,
of,
of fighter.
It's,
it's really as a person who's been involved in the sport,
as long as I have,
I still never cease to be amazed at the level of talent of these guys coming up.
Because some of these guys coming up,
they just could do everything and they can do everything.
It's such a high level and you realizing you're,
you're seeing the results of kids that started out learning MMA when they went
five,
six years old men,
you know,
I had a purse,
I have a personal gym and I remember Rhonda Rousey.
We like,
man,
she's going to change my bottom line.
All of a sudden I got a mat full of,
uh,
young women just trade fight.
I was like,
this is,
thank you Rhonda.
Yeah,
chief for sure changed it.
Gina Carano changes a little bit before her,
you know,
people had this idea like,
oh,
you could be pretty and fuck people up.
Like,
oh,
that's a totally different kind of girl.
That's like a superhero,
like a real life superhero.
Now she plays it and movies.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean it's just incredible too that the sport,
when you look at women's MMA,
like,
uh,
particularly Amanda Nunez,
Cris Cyborg,
that fight,
I mean,
that is as crazy exciting as any fight you will ever see in your fucking life.
And Amanda Nunez bombed on the one of the greatest,
if not the greatest women's MMA fighter of all time and k odor in the first
round in spectacular fashion.
Like if you're not a fan of MMA,
women's MMA after watching that,
like,
it's funny you mentioned that.
I just think about Holly Holm,
like what she made out of a million fights.
Like what is she doing?
So,
right.
Like he's just,
she's a,
you know,
GSP couture,
she just genetic specimen and I think she,
you know,
she just,
again,
she does that 52 week fight camp type deal,
you know?
Right.
Yeah.
You don't see her ever getting out of shapes and that's not how,
yeah.
You know,
I still think she got a raw deal and the random he fight,
uh,
she did.
She did.
She got clocks pretty,
pretty late.
Two Times hard to the buzzer.
Absolutely two times and no,
no,
no points taken away.
No nothing.
And we were shocked.
We were like that crazy.
And then on top of that she dropped her,
she dropped her with a head kick and she dropped her the straight left.
Like in my opinion,
she did the more damage in that fight and I was,
I was shocked.
But that's mean Emma made judge.
Yeah.
It's never going to dad's crazy.
He cannot help you with that at the performance institute.
But we got some data.
What I was getting at before when you were talking about little kids when I was,
I was rather talking about kids coming up and amateur fighters.
There would probably something that would be really beneficial of having some
sort of a program like that in America where kids could understand the right
way,
the wrong way to do it,
so they don't have to repeat these problems and these,
these mistakes that have already been kind of gone,
gone over.
And that's your background and the British Olympic.
So set that up.
Right.
You said that,
would that be something that the UFC would ever think about doing in the future?
Because if they really wanted to ensure that they had a good pool of high level
talent,
it would certainly add to that.
Yeah.
I mean there's no clear performance pathway into the w you know,
the highest level of the UFC for the sport of mixed martial arts.
So,
but there's guidelines for training that I think she might not have.
Every gym has a curriculum and what we're to do is obviously
add to that curriculum from us,
just from a training perspective or [inaudible] perspective.
But ultimately what's,
what's the best pathway?
And as you've already contested too,
people are coming to this bolt with so many different backgrounds.
So are you going to chop that the x access route to to the UFC in,
in half for yesterday?
Uh,
going to promote it and find you know,
many ways to get into the UFC.
I think,
you know,
we can look at things like the Olympic Games.
It does MMA ever,
ever entered into Olympic Games and create a pathway.
Who knows and I'm sure the UFC are looking into that type of thing in the future
and trying to be ambitious,
but right now it's hard to define what's the,
what's the optimal way and what it,
what is the optimal route into the UFC.
It is a really,
that's one of the more interesting things about,
and like we were saying before,
you could really have any combat sport path boxer wrestler,
anything could get you in there.
I'm sure it's the same for other disciplines of martial arts,
but I have a lot of experience in kind of youth wrestling development.
And when Emma May came along,
it was a little bit of a fear we're going to lose a lot of athletes to MMA.
And we did originally lose a lot of athletes on the Olympic level to MNA.
Johny Hendricks is a great example.
Promising young wrestling star,
went to MMA,
became UFC champ,
did not become an Olympian.
Um,
but what it's really done is it's created this popularity in wrestling in no
small part to I think some of the,
uh,
the feedback that you've provided around wrestling been so vital to the
development of,
of mixed martial arts.
But there's been a real boon,
I believe in youth wrestling and in,
in,
you know,
youth and high school wrestling because people realize and recognize that this
is a pathway into,
uh,
you know,
into becoming an elite mixed martial artists of all the athletes that are in the
UFC.
You know,
there's a very high level of champions right now that we're 2008 Olympians.
Um,
but if you look at the roster and how many people wrestled in high school,
it's staggering.
And so just getting this base,
uh,
not only technique in the grind mentality,
but the strength that you,
you know,
double egging somebody from when you're five,
until you're 18,
you develop strength that you can't develop when you're 22.
And this core strength and,
and the,
and the ability to do is,
is,
is a way to get into it.
And I know that other disciplines are likely receiving similar windfalls,
but in terms of developing that curriculum for,
for development,
and that's,
that's definitely part of the,
you know,
what we're interested in,
in alleviating some of the,
the big,
the big mistakes,
but there's still innumerable ways to get into it.
Think about when you're doing Jujitsu,
you had to like struggle to find people roll with when you started,
right?
Sure.
It was like,
there's like six guys,
so you're worth now you can go anywhere.
Like you can be doing a show in any,
uh,
just look up and go drop in on our local Jujitsu club.
That's panel jocks,
noon class the other day.
I had 60 people in it.
Six zero like what the fuck?
There was nowhere to move there.
There's your talent development pathway to the UFC,
those kids classes,
right?
Yup.
Yeah.
Um,
it's,
it really is interesting too and it's dependent upon if
a kid lives in an area that has a strong Jujitsu program or a strong Moitai
program,
oftentimes that's what dictates what path they get into the sport from.
No Dope.
Well good,
good women's wrestling program.
Yeah,
Russell,
like a girl,
I'm on the advisory board so I'm not only women's MMA but women's wrestling as
well.
And there's,
what's really interesting working on the,
on the kind of the clinical side of,
of what we do with the Pi is every discipline has its own,
not only sport culture,
but physiology that goes with it.
You know,
as we talked about,
the strength dynamics for wrestlers
are going to be different than the,
the,
the reactive strength for,
for our strikers and then nutrition and,
and just overall lifestyle type sport cultures is really interesting coming from
the different disciplines that you came from.
Boxers,
they do the road work.
They're doing a lot more fast and morning training,
uh,
wrestlers that have obviously a weight cut culture that they bring with them and
have a little bit more experienced there.
A lot of the Brazilian jujitsu players,
especially from Brazil have their sport culture.
So it's so intriguing being able to,
you know,
we work with one sport but with so many subcultures within that sport and a
really,
really interesting to,
to to get to work with.
And obviously working with the female athletes like you alluded to earlier,
adds a whole nother layer in terms of the dynamics that we're working with.
In terms of the physiology with,
I was just like the female physiology and the way cut.
That's just the whole like you really need to go to school for that.
Yeah,
I would imagine that's a big difference.
Now you help them organize their weight cuts.
I know you work with Camaros,
man,
for his cut for his last fight.
Okay,
so with tomorrow
we,
we absolutely worked with them all the way through,
all the way through the fight.
Did you guys know he had a broken foot?
Uh,
he was limping around but you know,
no we didn't.
And if we did we wouldn't have mentioned it.
But no,
I had no idea.
And and crazies,
that guy,
hey,
I did know he,
you know,
that's,
that's awesome.
I was actually happy.
Keeps in the building for the whole time and I didn't know that I was happy.
I was like,
yes,
good,
good job.
What happens in the walls stays in these walls because if there's this place
like the performance institute and it's run by the UFC.
Oh the,
the UFC that that pays me to fight people.
I'm worried that that's going to get to them.
Right.
So of course the fingers go through when we started this,
like I don't want to know,
like I'm the liaison from them to the other side of the half.
I don't want to know whose weight is what.
I don't want to know who's got a nagging injury.
That's your,
you know,
some of that is actually Hipaa,
information.
That's your private stuff though.
Even if it's just how strong or weak you are.
If you're having a bad day,
I don't,
I don't want that to ever get out of our walls.
Right.
So that's obviously a conspiracy guy.
That's,
you know,
what does have to do with conspiracy.
Yeah.
Guys always think the UFC is out to get them to,
I always thought like,
ah,
they're going to find out that it got this or that and you know,
well,
you know,
there's,
turns out for me the stress of preparation,
a fight.
I mean
people were always worried,
especially if there's a little tweak,
something going on,
something with the hand,
something with the leg,
with the knee,
he will,
it gets out.
People find out about to hear about it.
Do I get it?
Yeah.
That's the thing.
It's a thing Comoro in every other athlete we work with comes in with sensitive
injuries and we have a private treatment suite within the performance institute,
the Pt area.
Um,
so they can come get private treatment.
And then in terms of,
you know,
supporting him for,
for his weight cut that,
that starts 10 weeks,
12 weeks for,
for tomorrow,
you know,
three,
four months in advance.
How much you're trying to get him down to before the day of the cut.
So every athlete is going to be a little bit different based on what their
background is,
what is,
what does comfortable cutting from what their historical we cutting,
uh,
practices have been the how hard they've been on the body.
So we're,
we're assessing somebody like tomorrow for their metabolic rate where,
where they fit in terms of their body composition into that weight division
would lean tissue versus their,
their fat tissue.
Those that have a higher degree of lean tissue,
we're going to have muscle,
has more water than,
than does fat and bone.
So you can't push the body a little bit further for those that have a higher
lean tissue.
Um,
and so all of that planning and preparation starts many,
many weeks in advance.
And having heard a commercial on your show a couple of weeks ago,
uh,
a lot of,
a lot of what we do with an athlete that doesn't have a history of missing
weight may have a hard time making weight,
but oftentimes they're making it harder on themselves because they're pulling
the body in two different directions.
Like we talked about.
If they're training in one way and feeding in a different way,
what they're doing is they're just undermining and kind of digging a digging a
hole that they can't get out of by the end of fight camp.
And that fight camp gets really long,
like forest talked about.
What do you see in terms of the way they fueled themselves?
It's like the biggest error sticking to one,
one style of feeding regardless of the training style that they're engaging in.
So MMA athletes,
they have to do high intensity training sessions,
strength and conditioning.
They have to be doing spa and they have to be doing pads rounds that are you
crazy hard,
um,
in,
in every athlete.
Each one is going to have a different intensity relative to,
to,
to their body type.
And so if somebody is doing pads,
it's a nine or a 10 out of 10 in terms of intensity and they're doing that fast
it or they're doing that without carbohydrates available to do that work.
They can't,
they can't a hit those training intensities repeatedly and then they can't adapt
as a response to that training.
So they end up just getting slower and more beat up instead of faster and more
powerful.
So if they're doing high intensity,
we need to fuel the body in the specific way that supports that training effort.
And then the longer term adaptation to that bout.
Additionally,
if they're doing lower intensity,
we can adjust our fueling strategies based on what that dictates.
You know,
if it's,
uh,
kind of a base of robotic training session or if they're doing skills and
drills,
we want to be feeding the body to adapt differently than if they're doing the
high intensity sparring,
strength and conditioning or pads,
what do whatever that might be.
So for every athlete,
we're looking
at how their body uses substrate energy,
the energy that they're using,
the sub strait between carbs and fat at each of these intensities.
And then we also needed base it based,
we need to base our recommendations on where their body fits into the division.
If they're,
if they're 20% out from their weight division four weeks out,
then we're going to have a little bit of a more aggressive strategy
nutritionally because it weight becomes a primary factor.
If they're 10% out,
four weeks out,
then we're going to have a little bit of a different conversation and
prioritization around the fueling strategies and all of these conversations
integrate within our strength and conditioning program so that we're working in
concert and tying in the workload into our own system as well as the training
load that they're engaging with,
with their skill specific training.
Now when you vary the Diet that you give them independent dependent of the
workout,
what does,
what does that based on?
Is that based on a hard accepted science of carbohydrate versus protein versus
essential fat essential fatty acids?
Like how do you determine that?
So we,
we,
we use a philosophy,
a system called metabolic efficiency.
You could call it metabolic flexibility.
I've heard it called as well.
And essentially the body will use different substrate at different intensities
and at low intensities and at rest the body,
uh,
can and likely should be adapted,
for our,
for our sports athletes to,
to fat at rest.
Now it depends on the sport type.
Again,
if we're a shot putter or if we're a 100 meter sprinter,
then we're going to be much more dependent on carbohydrates and,
and,
and really the creatine phosphate system.
We're not even getting into the glycolytic system.
And Dunkin could talk a lot more about the energy systems,
but essentially we're,
we're reliant upon glucose and ATP for energy at those lower intensity bursts.
Right?
So to hit repeated Max or sub Max efforts,
we require blood sugar.
And without it,
we will deplete our,
our initial stores.
And then we can't,
we can't,
we can no longer hit 90 or 95% of our Max.
We start hitting 80 and 70 and 60 and,
and diminishing our ability to do these high intensity efforts.
Now,
do you guys see anybody come in and try to fight on a Ketogenic Diet?
Because I know quite a few guys were doing that for awhile.
I know Bryan Caraway did it.
Matt Brown.
Yeah,
that's right.
He has fought,
but he varies and I think he,
yeah,
well I talked to him.
I think he did one pretty pure and many did.
You know,
he did.
The one where you,
you know,
you might take in 60 or 80 carbs,
puffin,
you work them off to stay Kitteridge.
I don't,
some of those guys like Zack bitter.
Um,
he's a ultra marathon runner.
He v he does eat ketogenic most of the time,
but then on days of big races he'll consume a lot of sugars.
And,
and again I'll insulin sensitivity to,
yeah.
So essentially the more we can regulate blood sugar at rest and low intensities,
then we can expand and,
and to support the development of that kind of a Rubik oxidative system.
And by adapting to use fat as a primary substrate,
we're,
we're doing a number of things.
One,
we're balancing blood
sugar at rest so that we can really limit the insulin spikes and,
and essentially adipose development.
Um,
in addition to really
driving the body towards the oxidative and,
or the OC state of aerobic system.
And then as we increase in,
in what we do is we assess how the body adapts.
So through the training intensities,
and we'll repeat that kind of on a monthly basis to see how the athlete changes.
And then as they increase in the intensity of a training effort,
then we will adjust the ratio of fat to carbohydrates as,
as a fuel substrate.
I thought it was going to come up organically,
but it didn't,
uh,
the Trifecta of five prep systems,
you guys in your team have grown to 22 events this year.
Indeed.
Take it away.
All right,
what are you doing?
So I shouldn't have promo here.
Joe Stepped back.
So essentially we're assessing and then we're programming based on each
athlete's needs.
So,
um,
like for said,
one of our most valuable partners at the UFC performance institute is meal Prep
Company,
uh,
called trifecta nutrition.
And they essentially have all organic meal line that can be,
uh,
developed all the cart,
ordered all a cart.
And so with tomorrow as an example,
we worked together for his past two fights and and many athletes,
like I said,
uh,
are,
are not fueling the type of training in a way that leads to their long term
adaptation but can lead to overtraining earlier on campus.
So what we really won't want to do is to understand how that physiology works
and then program and then provide those athletes with the nutrition,
whether it's onsite at the,
you've seen performance institute at the event as well as what I was getting at
like 22 events they go to.
So you think about it like I would,
you know,
I would literally smuggle oatmeal into Brazil.
Like you're stealing food,
you know,
they,
they're like,
you get there,
you know the little thing that says no organic,
the little pass,
they can go to those fights and actually feed you throughout the week.
Oh Wow.
That's where I was going with that.
Sorry.
So that's incredible.
So they would like,
if you had a fight in Stockholm,
they would come to Stockholm with life.
If it's one of the 22 events.
Oh,
okay.
So
they would go and you could get the UFC pie to fuel you through the entire
event.
Yep.
So there's,
there's a a number of levels.
So I'll get there in just one sec.
But essentially we'll take them through the fight camp,
fuel them for adaptation.
So they show up to the event,
we know exactly where they are,
they're fueled.
And then we could take them all the way through the fight.
So 22 events,
most are domestic except for some the paper views that are,
that are international.
So of the 22,
the only international ones are the paper views.
The others are the ESPN events and those are pretty much exclusively domestic.
But what we,
what we've done is we've outreached all of the athletes that have crossed paths
with us at the performance institute.
So it's not,
it's,
it's not roster wide yet.
As we're working through a lot of the operational stuff,
as an example,
uh,
we aren't able to get into the kitchen at every hotel.
So then we're working to find a community kitchen,
trying to find contacts at local universities,
actually cook them yourself.
So trifecta hired a chef.
So trifecta,
they're our partner.
Uh,
they,
they've,
they've been amazing in terms of,
you know,
trying to feed our athletes.
We identified this as a real need to,
you know,
we,
we run a marathon with these guys,
right?
Kamara as an example.
We worked together for three months.
We get them to a week before the fight and then it's like pat them on the bubble
and say,
good luck.
We,
as we know,
fueling is,
is impactful all the way through the fight in,
in including 30 minutes before.
And so instead of them on the buck and say button saying good luck,
trifacta hired a chef who I previously worked with the,
he worked with me at Cornell University,
um,
for,
for a year.
He was an intern with me.
He worked at Exos for two years and then at a two star,
two Michelin Star restaurant here in La.
And uh,
uh,
providence is the name of it and he got hired.
He's their executive chef and is building out the fight week meals based on me
and my teams program.
So we work with every single athlete that we've connected with at the Pi.
Uh,
it's gotten up to,
on average between 14 and 16 athletes at all the events that were working.
And we provide comprehensive fueling.
Uh,
so all of the food calories that they put in their body from the time they step
on foot on Tuesday for fighter checking all the way through,
you know,
30 minutes pre-fight including all the supplements,
NSF,
third party tested supplements for supplement safety to make sure they're not
getting adulterated products,
were keeping track of everything that they're consuming.
On the supplement side.
We don't sit in the sauna,
we're not there to be a weight cut coach.
We are the weirdest sports dietetics team to support them on a,
on a,
on a programming and on,
uh,
you know,
science evidence base level.
Uh,
so we,
we,
we will consult with their teams around what's the safe was,
what's the most effective way to support an athlete making weight.
And then we instantly,
once they make weight,
we have supplies that was developed,
cooked,
prepared by our chefs that morning and the night before to support rehydration
electrolytes to,
to optimize the gut,
a repopulation of Gut Microbiota as well as balanced the osmolality so that
they're not getting gut cramping and,
and issues that happen when you ingest a ton of sodium and,
and glycogen or sorry,
in glucose,
that causes a lot of water to rush into the gut.
And then we essentially feed them all the way through,
like I said,
breakfast,
lunch,
and then pre-fight to support their,
their performance on fight night.
Um,
I'm an outspoken spoken critic of cutting weight.
I don't necessarily think it's the best thing for the sport or for the athlete.
I mean I think one of the benefits that we would get out of having more weight
classes available at fires could get their body to the weight class where
they're optimally at.
Has there ever been any discussion?
I know you guys have had discussions about ped usage and how to stop adulterated
supplements from getting to fighters and making people test positive.
But what about some longterm goal of eliminating
weight,
cutting the way they've eliminated pds?
So as we already talked about,
I come from college wrestling tragically in 1997,
three college wrestlers died in Florida.
Of course it's always Florida,
was it?
No
one was at the University of Michigan.
And uh,
I,
I'm not,
I'm not exactly sure where the other two were,
but let's pretend there were Florida,
let's say Florida to feels like Florida.
Florida is just going to shake their head anyway,
not even going to check except it,
but the NCAA dramatically overhauled their way in rules,
um,
from the day before to the day off.
And there are a lot of similarities in terms of the types of athletes that are
wrestling versus the types of athletes that are competing in MMA.
But we work in and we work with professional athletes and we work for a
professional fight promotion and,
and the dynamics of a professional fight promoter is completely different than
the NCAA and the re the re,
the level of autonomy with our independent contractors versus the incident
athletes is different.
And we as the UFC,
WWE,
you know,
the performance is do we have the health and safety of our fighters in mind at
all times.
And,
and that's priority number one.
And I've,
I've had to literally call the ambulance on athletes that,
that I've seen not doing well because of healthy health considerations.
Now you personally,
how do you feel about it?
About weight cut out?
We cut.
I would like to,
um,
I personally would like to make it safer.
Um,
there,
there are,
uh,
there are less than ideal.
Um,
I think safety concerns,
you know,
that we've all heard of and you know,
a lot of us have seen,
um,
and,
and from,
from my perspective,
the closer that you can bring it to,
to the fight,
the better.
But because of the promotional nature of the UFC,
it's limited.
And then we have,
we have limited ability to affect change,
et cetera.
The commissions,
the commissions really are the ones that are,
are,
I don't really make him a rule like that asshole.
But Dude,
pick your way class,
make the weight or just say,
you know,
I'm not going to be able to do it.
I've got to move up.
Right.
You know,
like it was always hard for me to admit to a five,
but you know,
I didn't really want to fight heavyweight and I made it and towards the end of
my career I walked around like,
you know,
I used to get pretty big and I was like,
Hey,
I don't want to do that.
I want to be a professional,
be a professional.
It comes back to the whole,
I hate keeps saying up with the 52 week fight camp.
All right,
like do you need to get 20% over your fight weight if you're 20% over your fight
weight,
that's not your fight weight.
You know,
just making very good points.
Just just,
I mean you can,
there are weight classes.
All right,
maybe there needs to be a way class,
like every,
well there it is.
Like every 10 days,
10 pounds.
Okay,
well every
10% so I think percent's a lot more important than the other thing is maybe in
time it will happen.
There's 570 athletes is not enough to fill that many weight classes and then you
know,
you're a boxing guy or you,
you know,
then you get away class.
I'm just going to run around and we're going to have fights every three pounds
and then it,
then it becomes a little,
hmm.
Well,
I don't know if that's necessarily the men.
There's like 27 belts.
How much time do they have?
Really clearly is that it's an,
it's an unnecessary risk to have a guy dehydrate themselves or a girl dehydrates
and seltzer that literally to the point of going to the fucking hospital 24
hours before a cage fight isn't saying,
if you could eliminate that,
why wouldn't you?
That's the number one thing.
I think there's no benefit whatsoever to making people dehydrate themselves 24
hours before a cage fight.
It seems crazy that,
no,
nobody's going to disagree with you,
but we,
wow.
What's the best way to figure it out?
The best way to figure it out is to,
first of all,
you can definitely avoid a lot of struggle and tragedy by figuring it out.
Right?
I mean the,
the fights that happen where,
wait,
we're fighters,
um,
in several organizations cut weight and died during that process.
That's heartbreaking.
You know,
if we could avoid that,
it's already dangerous sport as it is.
We are collecting data at the performance institute.
We,
we all have some opinions around what works best in terms of reducing the
extreme way.
Cutting,
creating some competitive parody in the cage I think is a really,
really critical points so that it d incentivizes that process.
Yeah.
If you can't be as big in the cage will then,
right.
Then there's not as much of a benefit.
The problem,
well it is a very complex problem and the regulation and in mixed martial arts
is such that we,
the promoter and we abide by the regulations of every single state athletic
commission.
And so we are,
we are collecting data.
So that we can understand the issue better.
We're co,
you know,
we're working to come to an understanding to then share with those that are the,
the,
the legislators of the system so that they can help make it safer as well
because it's not just a unilateral decision where we tell our employees what you
do.
We have,
we have 570 independent contractors.
So each of us has,
has some strong beliefs and opinions in this space and I,
I value years and I really respect that the passion you bring to it.
Um,
this is,
this is my passion as well.
That's why I came to the UFC is to,
to impact this culture and hopefully on the policy side as well.
But it's a very,
very complex system that we're working to,
to kind of,
you know,
infiltrate or to effect from the inside.
I truly understand that it's complex,
but if you could wave a magic wand and not have weight cutting,
wouldn't you do it?
Fuck yeah.
Yeah.
Nobody's disagreeing with that.
Why not just listen to you magic that they can do that one fc is doing it.
It can be done.
You just,
you have a program where you make sure that people move up a weight class,
they don't,
you have hydration tests.
You make sure that they're never,
never really taxing
out.
Like some guys,
we've seen some guys,
I've seen guys shuffle to this to the scale cause they couldn't walk.
We've all seen where guys are literally on death's door 24 hours for a cage
fight.
That's crazy.
Have you could eliminate that.
I can mend one of c for trying.
There's holes in that system just like there's tools in any sense,
but let's always going to try and game the system.
They're trying to game the system as well.
Well I remember being on a stick that you are accurate.
Go buy and Walmart.
Those aren't that easy to be or that those aren't hard to beat the hydration
tests.
Yeah.
Nope.
They're not.
You know,
you're 100% right.
I mean,
but it's more more,
it's more protected that it's more difficult to do.
They have a,
they have a far different regulatory system than we have as well.
We have 50 independent state regulators.
We have combined Jay down.
Yeah.
Down in Brazil we have different regulators.
It's,
it's very complex and,
and I think that we obviously here at the table and it,
the performance is to have,
have that as a,
as a primary kind of area of focus.
But we're,
we're,
we're working to affect the systems that can,
what Clinton,
his team are doing is,
let's see the dad,
like,
let's collect the battle,
let's figure out what it looks like.
You know,
what,
uh,
Don has been doing for the last couple of years collecting every fight weight.
Let's see.
You know,
let's,
let's look at the bat and figure it out from there.
Yeah.
Um,
it's,
uh,
it's just such a,
it's such an unfortunate aspect of it that I get has been there from the
beginning or at least from the time that weight classes started being
instituted.
Um,
but it just seems to me that boy,
if there was a way to avoid that,
they had to had it.
Right.
The Gi guys rather that throwed with the Gi guys.
Are Those added like Jerry,
wait,
yeah.
We'll go back to that.
Yeah.
The cage fighting pretty hard by itself.
Yes it is.
Yeah.
I just,
um,
we don't call it a cage Friday,
we call it octagonal struggle.
We've got a PC that shit out.
Yeah.
Well you see cage fighting.
People go,
what did he say?
Oh,
mixed martial arts.
you mean like the UFC?
I love Ron.
Drowsy.
Yeah.
I'm a big fan.
Hey,
it's about your messaging and sometimes,
yeah.
Accepted that.
Do you guys have a longterm plans for expansion of a,
the treatments and different things you do?
Do you have like a look,
is this something that you guys are constantly working on improving?
Yeah,
I mean absolutely.
The,
the sports science landscape is vast,
you know,
and,
and we try to keep abreast of all the ladies technologies,
the advantage in theory and philosophy.
So yeah,
that's at the heart of everything we do.
You know,
we're trying to and stay at the cutting edge of sports performance.
So
how does that,
does,
do you have to go to conferences and find out what the latest stuff guys are
doing?
I mean,
I,
you know,
I did the math this week actually.
You know,
I always say the church isn't the building,
the church is a people,
our staff has got a combined experience in pro and elite sports of 106 years.
We've got 18 Olympic Games supported within our staff alone.
Wow.
Okay.
So our people,
our staff,
our what is so precious to the performance institute,
um,
and we're very proud of our staff and their respective world leaders in their
own individual areas.
Um,
well yeah,
of course you have to go and speak to people.
Of course you've got to listen to seminars and collect and gather information or
conferences or what are you going to do is process it.
You know,
there's,
there's this,
there's a lot of pseudo science and Bro Science out there,
you know,
so you've got,
you love that word,
right?
Yeah.
It's a real problem.
So,
you know,
the,
the ability to process it is what makes the difference,
you know,
but
valid are about,
everybody can be fortunate enough.
I don't even have to be smart.
I just went out and found a bunch of smart people.
Does it make you take notes when they make you sit on these conferences?
Honestly used to really like try to obscure myself and everything and at some
point I was like,
Nah,
just hey Clint,
come here.
I've got a crushed now in terms of uh,
like recovery stuff,
I know you guys had a hot pool,
like a sauna or a Jacuzzi rather.
It was
right next to a cold plunge.
How much of that stuff do you guys do and what,
what,
what equipment do you guys keep the risk?
Again,
both Sandoval,
who's our head of strategy directors during the conditioning puts it,
you know,
intimately in terms of the,
in the UFC,
everyone's training hat,
you know,
every,
you're not training harder than the guy next to you or in the gym next to you.
What,
what is the key is how fast you can recover and train again at the intensity
that you need to the day after day after day and be robust enough to tolerate
that.
So recovery and regeneration is just as important as the training.
And exposure.
In fact,
your body obviously changes and adapts during the recovery and regeneration
process.
So yeah,
listen,
we've got hot tubs,
we've got aquatic capabilities,
we've got cryotherapy,
we've got compression,
we've got,
you know,
everything that you would expect in a,
in a,
in a world class facility.
What we're starting to do is really try to be a bit more prescriptive around
that.
Um,
as,
as clinics already talked about,
you know,
it makes no sense to us to look at a high neuromuscular striking session where
you're hitting myths or hitting bags and use the same recovery strategy as a
high metabolic grappling session.
These are totally different physiology,
physiology challenges.
So yeah,
to be prescriptive and to be a bit more strategic in our approach.
Um,
but at the end of the day,
what is core quarter recovery?
It's such a personal thing.
You know,
some people don't like getting in the cryotherapy chamber.
Some people can't swim,
so they're not going to get in the water and do hot cold plunges.
It's just,
it's going to stress them out more.
So,
you know,
hey,
go in here.
Drown.
It'll help you recover.
It's not that deep.
But there's,
you know,
there's some people just cut the fear of water cause you can't swim,
so they do about baths while shower too.
Crazy.
Your mom,
when you smell,
do you guys have a sauna on premises as well?
We do.
Do you have guys go from the sauna into the cold plunge?
Me Personally.
Yeah.
It's supposed to be a great benefit of,
right.
Yeah,
for sure.
And again,
you,
you know,
you've had Andy Galpin on about all these Brian,
Mackenzie,
all these people that breathing also.
There's a lot of information Rau around recovery,
but it's still a massive gray area massage.
Do you have that on staff as well?
Absolutely.
I therapists can do they do like,
uh,
like um,
raw feeling that kind of like deep tissue stuff.
Graston and all that though.
How often do you guys recommend that for athletes?
Because the,
the,
the Soviets for a long period of time,
it was really shocking when we found out they weren't massaging their athletes
every day.
And,
uh,
there's,
there's debate as to whether or not that's good or bad.
Like what are you thoughts on that?
Well,
I think what Heather,
who's a director,
a director of PT will tell you is that the,
the Fascia and the fighter posture and the way he fights is,
are putting their bodies through particular challenges obviously creates a lot
of muscle tone and it creates a lot of tightness in the Fascia and just methods
and mechanisms to free that up to,
to allow the joints and the articulation of the body to work effectively is
huge.
If you have greater than a,
I'm trying to remember the numbers,
but a,
uh,
at a,
um,
a 10 to 20% imbalance in a joint within your body,
you now have a 70 to 90% chance of injury that,
that joint,
right?
So just the,
the,
the difference in terms of symmetry and balance within the body and its
influence on injury is massive.
So why,
why,
why not be proactive in trying to utilize manual therapies and recovery
modalities rather than working in a reactive process and waiting for the injury
to happen.
And again,
that's,
that's core of our philosophy is that there's been a big shift in the barometer
for,
for some of the fighters that come through the performance institute,
you know,
the clinic and the therapy is somewhere where you go and you're injured.
Well,
you know,
what we do is we promote it just as much as the strength and conditioning piece.
So when you talking about range of motion,
you including flexibility exercises,
do you guys incorporate a lot of that stuff as well?
Oh,
for sure.
But again,
it's,
you know,
the faders tend to be pretty flexible.
Um,
so again,
it's,
it's on an individual level,
but most strikers,
most people can kick in the head in the UFC.
That'd be pretty flexible
in individual orthopedic assessment.
Right?
So I am,
this is tight.
That is tight.
I would need to loosen you up.
We're going to put that in your routine,
right?
So everything is needs analysis driven,
So,
you know,
Brown or Tigger don't need to be any more flexible.
We can throw us,
put his legs,
he just needs to maintain his current flux moon.
Right?
So you,
it completely varies and if you've got like a stiff wrestler with someone who's
like,
just never really worked on there about the combat posture,
that internal rotation,
that combat posture where you constantly throw.
And then we just chronically doing that year after year,
he's going to set you up for some amount of tightness in terms of fascist.
So again,
I don't want to go outside of my scope of expertise,
but um,
we're,
we're very proactive in promoting fighters,
using modalities proactively rather than reactively.
So say if a fighter came in and they did a hard grappling workout and uh,
after the training,
what would you recommend and how much time?
Cause there's some thought that
the body should exist in an inflamed state.
Postworkout to fall zone depends on the phase of training and also for a certain
amount of time,
right?
And then there's more of a benefit of going into cryotherapy after like an hour
or so.
It's where the benefits and the risks,
again,
if,
if you're off camp,
what are you trying to do?
You're trying to break down your buddy so it can be overloaded and recover
better.
You know,
you,
you use not super compensation to take it to a new level of,
of,
of adaptation encounter.
When you're shopping in the knife ready for the fight,
you want to remove any type of fatigue because you're getting close to the
fight.
You need to optimize your training and all those peak to the performance and
fight night.
So,
you know,
there's gotta be a strategic,
we've got a paradise,
you recovery as you appeared as you're training loads in camp or off camp.
Um,
but yeah,
there's different approaches in different modalities that you've got to utilize.
So if you look at grappling and the metabolic demand that goes into the
wrestling and the grappling and that,
that's a lactic lactate kind of response.
That's a,
um,
you know,
a circulatory issue in terms of those,
those metal metabolites are circling around the body.
You've got to remove those.
All right.
So is that going to be something like a muscle pump,
tape recovery strategy that will help it remove it through the,
through the liver and into the lymph system?
I mean like one of those compressions and it might be a compression pant or it
might be hot,
cold,
hot,
cold.
The,
that the vessels will expand in the heart and the contract in the college you
get a natural kind of muscle pump.
And how many times you ask fighters to do that when they do a hot cold thing?
Do they do deserve a sequence?
Yeah,
I mean we,
we,
we have a preferred methodology right now it's about three,
three to four minutes,
four times in each,
uh,
just go back and forth,
four minutes finishing the call.
You look at other other experts and other professionals in the field,
they'll say,
sit in the cold bath for 20 minutes.
You know,
so it's,
there's still not the science,
not that the data and information out there to really support.
So how do you optimize them?
How do you know whether or not it's having that much of a benefit compared to
not doing that?
Ask the guy I'll suggest.
Yeah,
number one subjective.
Do you feel better?
You know,
the,
there might be no science around cryotherapy.
I'm not suggesting that,
but there might be no,
no,
no data and no science on it.
But if the guy walks out three minutes later and feels like crystal mine and his
body is fresh,
it's,
it's kind of worked,
right?
Yeah.
Well the norepinephrine,
the raising of the levels of it due to extreme cold exposure,
I think that's been proven.
I think cytokine developer,
he shot cold shock proteins and heat shock proteins,
both of them.
That's all proven stuff in terms of measuring the actual inflammatory markers in
the body.
But some people don't like it.
I'm just making the point that if you like that stimulation and you like that
sensation and you walk out,
you can forget the physiology.
Cause now we're tapping into psychology and that's still part of the recovery
process is it's beneficial for sure.
We're going to say,
have no idea.
So
it was important.
No,
I was going to say I will side track just in terms of recovery.
Nutrition is a core value of the recovery process as well.
So as much cryotherapy is you do,
if you're not recovering stimulating muscle,
you know,
converting from catabolism do anabolism providing nutrients for substrate
regeneration,
that's a critical component as well.
So that,
that,
that's,
that's critical.
What we aren't doing is providing tart cherry juice or hide antioxidants
immediately post training as well.
That yeah,
we'll,
we'll include that in,
in other periods of the day,
in the evening or,
or not,
or not immediately around a high intensity training session for an antioxidant
negative aspect of an intoxicant suppose training similar it,
it limits it blunts the adaptive response based on the,
the,
the body's recovery process.
So if you,
if you blunt your,
your immune response to,
uh,
to,
microtrauma muscle tears that need to be re rebuild stronger and faster,
well then you,
you limit the adaptation.
So yeah,
we want to provide nutrients to support recovery,
but we don't want to eliminate the adaptive response to,
to the training sessions.
That's what's so fascinating about the science of it,
that you can get that,
that specific that you know that if you consume the high levels of antioxidants
post-training,
it's going to blunt the recovery time.
That's so amazing.
Curcumin,
tart cherry juice,
there's a number of of spices that are included in a lot of different things.
So whether it's cooking or or in our supplement protocol that we will include,
but we're,
we're going to target them away from the high intensity,
far away from the high intensity track.
Couple hours,
couple hours.
I mean it comes back to you can kind of fights it,
kind of coach process,
all this information.
Can they physically be aware of it,
where the catch is giving it back,
write it down.
So again,
let us do some of the grunt work performance institute and we can give you some
of the education.
I'll tell you how I feel and then we'll come back.
We'll talk about it and maybe the changes coaches in gyms don't have to feel
like you're trying to poach them and take them away and bring them to a new
player.
That's the beautiful thing about it.
It's like it's open to everybody who fights for the UFC.
And the other thing which I would say is this,
this is at no cost to the fights.
It's all right.
It's also that choice when they're independent contractors,
they can decide how much they want to engage with us as much or as little as
they want.
And again,
that's the same with the trifecta program for meal prep.
It's the same with our strength and conditioning program.
So again,
it's,
it's all bespoke and customized program in at their expense,
at no cost to the fence.
It's so exciting for me because having seen the fight,
the fights and the um,
the,
the sport and the level of sport evolve over all these years,
it's so exciting to see constant and continuing innovation.
And when you guys came along and built this thing and I had a chance to go and
visit,
I was so excited because they're like,
this is just as what man,
every sport needs something like this.
But the fact that the UFC has this,
do some testing combined,
do some testing to find out I'm old,
we knew where are you more old than other hand.
Not My left hip.
I fell down skiing.
What would make it great?
Sorry,
can you make a great point because what's,
what's been one of the really exciting things
for us and refreshing,
um,
also for the UFC performance institute is that sports like the NFL,
the NBA,
um,
you know,
the English Premiere League where I'm in representatives from all of these
teams,
NHL co coming through and trying to understand or just be trying to understand
what we're doing,
how we're working our sports science into the sport of mixed martial arts and to
try and capture our philosophy and our approach from a facility development
perspective through to kind of our educational processes through to the way we
are interacting with fighters.
And again,
we're trying to shape mixed martial arts,
which I know influence the UFC.
That's,
that's an,
that's our number one mission.
But the,
the,
the global awareness around,
around the performance institute is,
is,
is really exciting as well.
Now,
I know you guys,
you were talking about your place in China.
Are you planning on going anywhere else?
Well,
right now,
um,
you know,
the,
the expectation or the,
our,
our desire is to influence mixed martial arts globally.
We're,
we're truly a global sport.
So,
um,
right now we don't know what that's gonna look like,
but the ambition is to obviously have performance institutes around the world
that can help the development process.
I want to build one in like South Africa.
Barris over there,
get the malaria medication ready,
bro.
Wow.
Cipro,
Cipro.
I don't know what that stuff is.
He just wants to red wine,
right?
Oh,
it's pretty nice too.
What is cool by is about us operating in athletes,
being independent contractors and accessing us however they see fit is we have
so many different case studies in utilization.
Uh,
we'll have people come out for a week at a time,
access our team,
take that back wall of other people come out for part of a camp or a full camp.
Others will come.
We had,
um,
Macy,
Barbara actually,
she talked about it publicly,
but she,
she worked with us quite a bit for her last fight.
She booked a flight from Nashville to Vegas to to reconnect to get updated
nutrition and strength and conditioning,
w whatever,
whatever metrics that we could update based on her health status as well as
orthopedic support,
post fight.
So we were able to get a number of days post fight as part of essentially the
completion of her fight camp to get her ready for the next phase.
So there's a lot of different ways that athletes can utilize based on just
whatever their needs are,
whatever they perceive their needs or needs to be.
And then whatever influence we're able to kind of make over over their
preparation.
And Macy,
Barbara is a perfect example of someone getting that kind of high level
treatment very early in a career.
She's only 20 years old to know super exciting prospect and for her to have
access to the 21 like three weeks,
she's all there at ey over the hill that that voice is Forrest Griffin.
Ladies and gentlemen,
no one else.
When you,
um,
when you treat these younger fighters,
how much emphasis do you put on giving them?
Um,
just some,
just a smart protocol to try to minimize the potential injuries to get them to
understand the relationship between range of motion and injuries to get them to
understand balance.
I know you guys have a machine that you actually can measure the muscles in the
body and show like the left and the right side.
What's,
what's,
what's weak and what's strong,
right.
What is that called again?
I mean we,
we use false plates in,
in,
in certain particular,
um,
there's something you lie down in though,
isn't there?
So we have the Dexa scan,
which is essentially a,
you know,
a low dose x Ray.
The measures the mass of the tissue between bone mass,
muscle mass and fat mass.
Um,
and so we can get a balance of,
of the musculature and the skeleton bilaterally when we,
when we see a big imbalance on that front because that,
that is a nutrition related test,
we will share that with both physical therapy and strength and conditioning.
And then physical therapy could break that into more nuance around strength and
balances around joints using the biodex and then strength and conditioning.
We'll do very similar,
uh,
kind of understanding using the,
the biolateral force plates that Duncan was mentioned.
Stupid machine told me I had two pounds less muscle in my left leg and my right
and it was accurate.
Oh yeah.
Now I do.
I blew up my day out with a couple of times,
but I just didn't rehab it properly.
So when you found out,
did you start doing like extra one legged pistols on the left side for two
weeks?
Maybe even three.
And then I was like,
yeah,
I got some emails,
the sense,
and now he just keeps running in circles.
Let me ask you this.
If you did see a fighter and they did have something like that and they were
active,
they're still competing,
you saw it happens all the time.
What do you do?
Yeah,
I mean we,
we have a lot of fighters that have imbalances muscularly that that's,
that's not a nutrition related.
Obviously our support is going to be important for the adaptation.
And this goes to Heather or around a orthopedic assessment,
what are,
what's the imbalance?
What's the injury risk?
Like Dunkin was saying in terms of strength and balances,
which she and her team had.
Their Linden are,
our director of PT would,
would do that orthopedic screen,
see what the imbalances are and break it down.
And then that would lead to probably programming in her space.
And then also to strength and conditioning to build programs around whether it's
mobility,
range of motion or,
or just around kind of hypertrophy to make up for some imbalances.
So that's where the comprehensive approach comes in.
I might assess something and then kick it over to them.
There's many cases where they would assess something,
whether the strength coach uh,
happened this week.
So and so's having a,
uh,
a bad training session.
They talk about low energy,
they talk about not being able to recover and get up for the next training
session.
That's an immediate referral over to my session to,
to,
to my side of the fence.
So that's where the integrated care becomes really,
really critical.
So a how,
if you had someone that had like a two pound weight difference between their
left leg and the right leg,
how much time would you give them to gain that weight back?
Would it be dependent upon the individual or like you would probably want that
to be a priority before they went into a heavy camp or something like that.
You can't resolve that immediately,
but that would be part of the,
I mean it comes back to the return on investment,
right?
Well,
what's the return on investment to the reduction of an injury risk,
uh,
to,
to try and influence that two pounds?
Do you know what I mean?
That,
that's a conversation that's a w w we're going to have that conversation around
how,
how effective or influential is going to be on the outcome of the fighters.
So,
you know,
as Glen says,
his fighters at Walt round truly imbalanced.
Um,
but what's the risk and the time and effort it's going to take to make that
change?
If it's in a fake count,
we're probably going to just leave it as it is.
If it's off camp and we've got a little bit more time to try and address it.
All right now we can be a bit more proactive about your hold.
We'll take you out back and shoot you.
Now they did a,
we messed around with some a BFR stuff,
blood flow restriction can sue type approach.
But again,
in in physical therapy and strength conditioning,
that's not revolutionary anymore.
That that's,
that's part of just another tool that we add to it.
It's,
it's a way to come to augment,
um,
or accelerate hypertrophy.
So if you have someone's coming back for returning from surgery or an injury and
you're looking to get muscle mass back onto the limb without necessarily loading
it through free weights or whatever it may be,
you can use blood flow restriction methods to try and increase the hypertrophy
mechanism.
What are you thoughts on the electrical muscular stimulation?
Also pants and sharpies.
Now,
now that it's called Heather,
they,
they uh,
they come by a lot with different machines.
So that's an amusing,
I have not,
no,
well,
actually,
no,
that's not true.
I was the test dominance test done.
Did it help you wrong?
I think with a lot of those things as some short term relief,
and again,
you're influenced the nervous system,
the longterm changes are potentially not there.
Here's our ask you about cupping.
So it legit.
Yeah.
Is it real Michael Phelps?
I won't see it.
It's amazing.
Michael Phelps in the Olympics,
if you think about massage,
that's all decompression.
What [inaudible] does is the opposite.
It lifts.
All right.
So again,
when we're talking about Fascia and changing faster and I'm releasing faster,
if all you ever do is massage and depressed the tissue,
you're not getting that mechanism of lifting and,
and,
and bringing it up into the cup.
So that,
that's kind of philosophy behind it.
And,
and our,
our therapists use it a lot,
but again,
it's just a tool and they're going to use the tool for certain situations.
And then I leave it for this.
Is there any scientific research to back cupping?
Not that I'm aware of,
but I might be completely wrong.
So,
um,
do you ever do it?
I got a couple of showing me like,
show me like,
what's going on with your leg bro?
Forrest Mars,
would you do so do you know,
do you know oppression from an,
also,
you had surgery six weeks ago.
Would you have done MCL,
PCL,
LCL,
Jesus,
man.
Do you know the single leg?
Uh,
when you do the scissor defense to the single leg?
I don't.
Oh No,
not at all.
I just fell right on his leg.
It turns out you can't do a thing.
Uh,
you can't not do a thing for six years and just think you can do it.
It's not riding the bike.
It's a,
it's a perishable skill as mere Clinton now,
now,
so how long ago?
But I have three new ligaments,
so I'm good.
Oh Geez.
Six,
six and a half weeks or three new ligaments from cadavers.
Is that what it is?
A MCL was able to be repaired down on itself.
PCO,
cadaver,
Lcl,
cadaver.
I'm getting world physical therapy on a daily
cupping today.
I got graston yesterday.
Hurt like hell,
but literally I'm just Beta testing everything.
I,
I was the test subject for Roman for all the exercise tests.
Now I'm the test subject for all the PT Rehab.
What about stem cells or exosomes or anything along those lines?
We've got our flights to pat them all booked.
Dr Neil Riordan on standby and I'm sticking with physical therapy at the moment,
but I,
I honestly don't know that much about the other components,
but I'm waiting for embryonic stem cells in the u s then I'll do it.
What does that mean?
They're doing a lot of
Achilles.
I have Tim [inaudible].
Yeah,
he's fantastic.
they're doing some incredible stuff.
If you're really interested,
you should talk to a doctor.
Rati Mcgee.
He's also local in Vegas.
Kelly.
Yeah,
he's amazing.
I did a consult with them.
You sent me,
you and cc both set mate and he said,
yeah,
uh,
for my shoulder.
And he was like,
yeah,
there's nothing there for it to attach to.
I'll take your six grand,
but it probably won't work cause I was like,
whoa.
I appreciate the character down him.
Yeah,
he's very,
he's very honest about the potentials.
But your,
your shoulder's been operated on how many times?
Three.
Yeah,
that's rough.
Now what are the options when something like that happens?
Can they,
I know they do shoulder replacements,
but what does that entail?
Yeah,
I'll probably do that eventually.
And what does that mean?
They just put a,
a different socket.
What'd they do it about?
All of the surrounding ligaments and everything?
I don't know.
That's terrifying.
I think a lot of those are still intact so I'm a,
the range of motion were improve as long as I go mess around in our PT once or
twice a week it stays functional.
So when you say mess around,
like what kind of stuff you're doing?
Some stuff for mobility or suffer?
Eat doing like clubs.
Well I like where you're actually like moving through with them,
like pressing on the muscles and you're actually like lifting the,
what's that called?
Where you were lifting weights or someone's window,
you're like,
ah,
I forgot.
I'll think of it in the,
sorry.
No worries.
Physical therapy.
Did you have,
you do a lot of it
band stuff and a lot of shoulder guys get band work?
I,
I do.
Uh,
yeah I do.
Um,
like as a warmup every day.
Yeah.
Or every,
you know,
every,
whenever I worked out except for today I just jumped in cold and my clothes.
See what happens now,
how much,
how much time do you spend,
uh,
on just sort of educating fighters about having to strengthen up all the,
the surrounding tissue around knees and shoulders and necks and things along
those seeds that are commonly your core,
your lower back,
commonly injured.
She resilience is massive in our sport cause again it's and range resilience,
right?
With,
with the submission and,
and,
and the,
you know,
the grappling exercise techniques,
you're taking
a tissue and the tolerance of that tissue to its end range.
So by being able to train that over time in a progressive fashion,
of course it's going to have an influence.
And yeah,
we,
part of our programming is going to approach that for sure.
Now you guys have been in action now for two years.
You've had a bunch of different fighters move through and do their camps there.
We've had a roster of 570 we've had over 430 of the fight is have already been
through in the first 22 months and we have a retention rate of about 73%.
So they're either coming back for repeat visits or the getting remote
programming from ourselves.
Now how much has this changed over the two years?
How much has have your protocols change?
A programs have changed a lot.
Yeah.
I mean,
yeah,
a lot.
We were learning more about the spa at the data is showing is smaller and you
know,
again,
just the opportunity to speak to more cultures,
more athletes.
Again,
W W we're servants to the fight community and w where sports scientists,
therapists,
clinicians,
um,
the end of the day the Ip sits with the coaches when they may coaches and people
like forest.
So just being able to understand how we can collect that information from a
technical,
tactical perspective and try and fit it into our philosophy of sports science
being complimentary to that,
that that's,
that's evolved all of our processes extensively over the last two years.
Have you guys ever thought about putting it in these sessions online?
Yeah,
I mean I,
oh,
the,
shouldn't,
I always say the performance institutes got three responsibilities.
The first responsibility is to serve as athletes to serve.
It's our fake community,
either face to face or remotely.
The second thing which we're trying to do something like this is to aggregate
more information and more insights around the sport.
It's only,
it's available and when you could buy this now,
but you can get it online through a,
you know,
it was sent to every,
on our,
on the average person,
you can go to our Twitter accounts and things like that and find on there,
there's links out there on social media.
Everybody knows a UFC fighter,
right?
Just go fine or borrow.
But,
but the second thing is we need to understand the sport,
the sport of mixed martial arts.
He's only 25 years old professionally.
So aggregating data is a second thing.
And then the third thing off the back of that,
that that data is dissemination and education across the global fight community.
So we were called the performance institute for a reason,
not the performance gym because we are truly trying to do project work,
do research work,
work with partners to try and aggregate that information and uh,
our awareness and our understanding so that we can push out there.
So the plan is obviously moving forward to really ramp up our educational
platforms to support the global community.
And hopefully we will have kind of certifications coming online and those types
of things as well.
Strength,
the amputee or filming stuff to put online to Russia.
This is the way this exercise properly done,
this things to look out for,
for physical therapy and a strength and ambition.
You know,
you guys have a youtube channel.
We don't,
we're,
we know what,
here's the thing,
we,
we don't want to act quickly.
This isn't,
we're not like a youtube thing.
We
want to lie Tate,
when we released something,
we stand behind it.
This is,
this is tried and true.
These are practice method.
We don't need to rush it.
Also,
these jerks are all always busy like working with assholes,
athletes,
Freud slip.
Well,
I think that would mean what you guys are doing is amazing and it would be even
more amazing if young fighters,
people coming up to get it right.
You really could influence a lot of folks.
It's in our ambition.
It's just what just to he is into this I first year was just,
shit,
let's just get operational.
We don't even know what this thing is.
Is anyone gonna cut mandate to the UFC?
Give you,
I mean,
how much,
what did they say?
Hey man,
make a fucking awesome place.
Who peekaboo.
Do their best.
All right,
this is Dana.
Hi Five.
I'm going back to work like how does that work?
How does,
how does it get set up?
It was like,
hey,
we want insights into the athletes.
We want,
you know,
event.
Uh,
it's origin was like,
Hey,
can you guys make people stop missing weight and getting injured so much?
And more importantly,
when somebody does get injured,
can we like get them back quicker?
Can they not work with like a mom and pop car accident chiropractor to get like
a professional app?
You know,
can we get them back?
So the,
the the goal,
right?
So the mission statement is,
you know,
so long gay careers too,
to help athletes make the weight class stay within the way class fight gray that
their weight class.
So again,
uh,
specific mandates like the exact Kpis,
I forget what they are.
There were some,
just off the bat,
what I would say is that we can legitimately say in the first 19 months of first
19 months of our existence,
we've saved 22 fights either through medical intervention or the work that
Clinton has done around someone that's behind the desk,
that white descent.
And we've really expedited that process.
So it's amazing that we're proud of that number and it's hard to build KPIs
around that.
But that's why the performance institute was implemented.
KPAS Kpis,
key performance indicators.
So when not a fight team,
right,
we work with the whole roster.
So now what,
we're not judged on wins and losses,
although some,
some would,
you would look on social media and some would think and but what,
what,
what our KPIs are around things like how can we support fights is make weights.
How can we get them to the door?
They ought to get in a healthy fashion.
And again,
22 fights.
We can absolutely say they probably wouldn't have happened if it wasn't for the
work of the performance institute.
So there's,
you can put a financial cost potentially against that and that that's kind of
the philosophy behind the performance institute.
Are Gentlemen,
any last words?
Clint,
you're gonna say something.
I was just going to add that that a lot of what we're doing in the,
in the athletes that we get to interact with are the cases that require huge
interventions.
You know,
people that are coming off of sixth fight,
win win streak or not looking for how to fix their metabolism or how to stop
missing weight or how to improve their power.
Because it's a deficiency or an orthopedic injury.
So we're,
we're,
we're working with those that are really successful and those that are
struggling and everything in between.
So it's around those,
those,
um,
interventions that have led to fights actually happening there.
There's a huge amount of,
um,
I guess risk for lack of a better term that were taken on as we're,
as we're,
we're really working with the athletes best interest at heart and doing
everything we can to support that athlete to be more consistent and to be able
to do at longer under their career,
uh,
so that they could,
you know,
do the best for,
for themselves,
for their family and for,
uh,
I guess the UFC.
Beautiful.
Anything Dunkin to add to that?
This is a trip,
you know,
in terms of where we're at with the performance institute,
our ambition is to really affect and support the global fight community.
That's what we're about.
And hopefully,
you know,
moving forward to see you w w w,
w you know,
people are going to see the value of what we're trying to do.
Well,
I think they already see the value.
I certainly do.
I'm very excited that you guys are around and what you do with the money.
I thought it's definitely going to be a waste of money and a good way.
What does that mean though?
Right?
We cost money,
but I think ultimately it's great for the sport for sure.
And uh,
I,
it's,
it's just an amazing resource and I'm glad you're a part of it too.
Me Really means a lot.
It means a lot to have a guy who's a former champion who's been there.
I mean,
since ultimate fighter season one,
you know,
I mean,
it's creamy.
Your fight.
I mean everybody says it.
It's a fact.
Your fight
at least once a day,
that fucking fight made the sport that you are in.
He was in a fight once.
Dad Five made the sport man really debt that,
that fight was so crazy.
People were calling up their friends like when they start doing the Nielsen
numbers are all shenanigans,
right?
You get like a hundred people there checking their,
they don't really know who the fuck's watch watching want,
but they know that something crazy happened to her in that fight.
And they'd have estimates that there was as much as 6 million people changed and
sort of tuning into that fight while it was happening.
They don't know what the real numbers are,
but it was chaos.
And then afterwards I never saw anything like it.
I've seen it was like all the sudden people wanted to watch the UFC.
It was almost instantaneous.
The season finale of the ultimate fighter went on the air and then they'll hold
the door open and people started pouring through.
It was crazy,
man.
And that's you,
you and Stephan Bonner,
you,
you guys were responsible for literally the birth of this explosion that you
are,
we're all seeing right now that we're seeing with this ESPN deal we're seeing
with these incredible fights.
No,
it's cool.
And,
and I,
you know,
I love that,
that I,
that to kind of be back that cornerstone,
but you know,
now the Pii,
the UFC itself,
the stars today,
it's only built,
you know,
that was the beginning.
There's,
you know,
there's so much more calm,
there's so much more to come,
but you're a bad mother.
Fucker.
Forest were there just,
just thrown.
Ever drill a Jujitsu Orion.
We were just a lump people.
But seriously,
I mean,
uh,
I'm super happy that you guys exist.
It's awesome for me.
It's been a treat for me as a fan for having a workout with you.
Learn all the inside stuff.
It's very exciting.
So thank you.
Much continued success.
Gentlemen,
please come visit as again.
I would look them anytime.
Thank you very much.
All right.